There's a very interesting new poll from the
University of Southern California, which is
making headlines because Joe Biden is winning
by 11.
I don't want to talk about that.
I've already told you, you know, Joe, up 11
with a margin of error of three and a half
means maybe Joe is only up four.
And if Trump picks up a point between now
and November, you could have the exact same
outcome as in 2016.
So I don't care about Biden up by 11:00.
What I care about in this poll is that it
looks at nonvoters from 2016.
OK, in the United States, embarrassingly tragically,
disgustingly, only about 55 percent of eligible
voters vote.
Forty five percent of those who could vote
did not vote in 2016.
The turnout was 55 percent.
The preliminary data from the University of
Southern California poll finds that among
those who didn't vote in 2016 but planned
to vote this year, 52 percent plan to vote
for Joe Biden, while only 32 percent plan
to vote for Donald Trump.
And another 16 percent say that they would
vote third party.
Now, it's also notable that among those who
voted third party in 2016, they are also leaning
towards Biden.
Forty one percent of those who were third
party in 2016 are going Biden, while only
30 percent of 2016 third party voters are
going for Donald Trump.
That's huge.
And of the people, when you combine that 71
percent of third party voters from last election
are not voting third party this time around,
which I think does go to the understood significance
of this election.
But I want to focus on the nonvoters.
Okay.
2016 nonvoters who are going to vote are leaning
towards Biden.
The obvious question is, how many people is
that right?
If there's a hundred thousand nonvoters from
last time who are going to vote.
That's very different than if there are 10
million nonvoters from 2016 who plan to vote,
if indeed 52 percent of them are going to
be voting for Joe Biden.
And just as importantly, how many people are
there who did vote in 2016 and don't plan
to.
This time around, no data on them.
Another important question, but this is another
signal that our instinct from a year and a
half ago continues to be proven true.
We are way better off trying to just mobilize
people to vote than we are trying to argue
with Trump's to get them to change their minds.
It's very clear that a majority of those who
didn't vote last time.
If we can get them to participate, that helps
Joe Biden.
Just finding nonvoters from 2016 and getting
them to vote helps Joe Biden.
If you can target it to people who are already
on the left but didn't vote.
That's the win.
Spending time arguing with Trump lists whose
brains have turned to mayonnaise is not a
good electoral strategy.
And then we get to the problem of voter apathy
in the United States.
There is no question, you know, when when
45 percent of the eligible voting public doesn't
vote.
There's no question that part of the problem
is we are not ingraining civic engagement
and the importance of voting from a young
age where if people are growing up in households
where, of course, you vote is the default.
If kids are not hearing in school as early
as whenever we vote, that is what you do.
If he if that was the situation, our turnout
would be far higher than 55 percent.
That's one part of the problem.
Our voting system is also part of the problem.
And we can't ignore that the system we have
dissuades voting.
And if you look at other countries without
mandatory voting, with significantly higher
turnout, you see that sometimes they have
different election systems.
New Zealand has a mixed member proportional
system.
Their turnout last election was almost 80
percent.
Germany has a mixed member proportional system.
Their turnout was 76 percent.
We have a first past the post system that
perpetuates the two party duopoly and dissuades
voting at all.
Now, many of you have called me during live
calls and you say, David, what the hell is
going on with third parties?
Why can't third parties get going in the United
States?
Part of it is the spoiler effect of the first
past, the post post system.
And part of it also is campaign finance.
So there are many problems here.
I don't believe that the intent of the founding
fathers was to create a system that dissuades
participation, but it's what it's become in
the modern voting era.
From the standpoint of this election, let's
target those who didn't vote last time.
It's a good idea.
The data backs it up.
We can't bank on nonvoters showing up.
Some of the least reliable voters are people
who didn't vote last time, unfortunately.
But the numbers are on our side.
Arguing with trombonists is a waste of time,
and the numbers show nonvoters from 2016 much
more likely to support Joe Biden than Donald
Trump.
I think it's an interesting area to focus
part on, particularly in battleground states
from here
on out.